deuxième chapitre de notre série sur les
petites radios deux pays et ce soir nous
partons pour aubenas en ardèche où est
d'installer fréquence fait cette radio
associative est née avec la libération
des ondes sur la bande fm en 1981
patrice morel benjamines jeune homme
terroir et gastronomie terroir et
gastronomie une émission présentée par
jean françois chalais et voilà le
nouveau terroir et gastronomie comme
dans les airs
on va parler de la ferme de khost cigale
bonjour à ses sophie janvier qui initie
la double coque d'un épicurien
alors ça te crève viennent
les arrivées aux alentours m que
consciencieux et rigoureux dans sa
cuisine du plateau ardéchois animateurs
gaillard et jovial au micro de la radio
locale
donc les zones de proximité s'est bougé
jean-françois chanéac l'un des meilleurs
cuisiniers du 07 anime une émission de
terroir sur fréquence 7
c'est plus simple d'être animateur que
chef
je dirais que ça va conforter les
professionnels c'est un métier et
l'autre j'ai l'avantagé mois dans des
trucs de mon métier à peu près j'ai
utilisées et de retranscrire ça je pense
aux vielles vignes possible que des fois
20 ans par exemple des gens ils sont
bien bon journaliste mais pas des topics
vous parle de ki moon excusez moi je
veux goûter le vin libres et sincères et
guy merlaud alors je sais pas pour ce
qu'ils savent c'est vrai l'unique membre
séquencé mechali différentes
une radio pas pareil en ardèche c'est
quoi ça l'agacé alexandra est animatrice
salariée à fréquence est aujourd'hui à
aubenas elle interviewe un chanteur
local
ce n'est pas jean ferrat les jeunes se
pointe avec des idées me dise voilà on
veut faire du hip hop on va faire du
r'n'b y ont offert de la chanson
française donc leur demande de penser à
l'asie de penser à ce qu'il voudrait
être plus tard à ce qu'ils ont à ce
qu'ils ont fait par le passé
l'important une radio une radio locale
comme comme fréquence est vraie elle
serait pas là on aurait quoi skyrock nrj
passe toujours la même chose
donc du coup on préfère s'orienter sur
fréquence est
ils font vraiment quelque chose de
différent complètement niveau musical
s'accrocher au pays et résisté depuis la
libération des ondes en 1996 et à la
radio de l'ardèche méridionale
ce sud du département où l'on chante en
parlant installé dans une ancienne
bicoque sur les hauteurs d'eau bonne à
cette radio associative s'est rendu
indispensable
attention pour moi c'est une drogue
voilà le directeur et vie sinon qu'est
ce qui motive justement rencontré
constamment des nouvelles personnes et
de les faire découvrir aux auditeurs se
pointe du produit quand c'est non c'est
pas une petite radio c'est la radio
ardéchoise ciblé fin
et puis même internationale maintenant
on est sur internet alors quelle
ambition gratuit c'est très plaisant
tout une radio country concept qui a
vraiment un esprit vraiment décalé même
musicalement commentant presqu'en temps
hier donc on découvre vraiment navré
c'est vraiment un grand musicien depuis
27 ans fréquence est préserve son
identité avec ténacité il en faut
d'ailleurs car les finances sont maigres
le budget annuel atteint péniblement
cent mille euros dont 40 mille apporté
par le fonds de soutien de l'état et
bonjour à tous vous êtes à l'écouté de
fréquences cet essai culture reggae avec
les voix de bolet dès jay salut salut
chez les jours il faut se remettre en
cause tous les jours il faut toucher
mais il faut trouver les fonds
nécessaires pour payer quatre salariés
tous les jours et il faut trouver de la
publicité il faut de monter des dossiers
donc voilà c'est au quotidien que vous
n'êtes pas dans le rouge financièrement
en sortir pas vraiment jusqu'à présent
on s'en sort pas mal on est venu on a
une économie très disons c'est vol c'est
à dire que on dépensera je connais quand
on a parlé par seconde
ces radios deux pays sont essentiels
mais fragile fréquence est doit sa
survie à une trentaine de bénévoles sans
eux
l'ardèche du sweat perdrait un petit peu
de son âme
c'est un pays que tu m as tu envie d'en
parler pour moi mais faire connaître
aussi tous ces petits produits sortent
de l'ordinaire
ce petit groupe volvo bus énergie
sauvage et puis vraiment non traités
donc ça lui a parlé